[Music]
drake was celebrating all weekend long
after the release of his new album
honestly never mind he was living it up
at a party hosted by dj khaled at miami
story with members of his ovo crew
and honestly never mind is already
breaking records it broke apple music's
record for heist's first day streaming
of a dance album within the first hour
of its release
but the dance album has received some
criticism from fans on social media and
drake didn't shy away from the reviews
addressing them in a video on his
instagram stories
it's all good if you don't get it yet
it's all good that's what we do
that's what we do we wait for you to
catch up
we caught up already
ahead of the release of the album drake
premiered the debut episode of his radio
show table for one on cirrus xm sound
42. i'm about to play you
an album that means the world to me
[Music]
and uh
yeah it took us about six seven months
to make maybe
and
something i always wanted to do shout
out to all my exes you know i saved you
and my phone as never again just so i
don't forget and the toronto superstar
also revealed he's got a lot more on the
way me and kenza have a book coming out
this year
yeah we have a book coming out to see
our poetry book i got another scary
hours pack coming soon a little bit i'm
not maybe not like maybe not right now i
need you to just take this in right now